wir sind nach exakt sei wieder da auf
dem bundesplatz mit dem gm er ist der
reporter taxi vor dem hungerstreik
befindet sich momentan am dienstag im
hungerstreik und ich wollte euch gutes
update was bei ihm gegangen ist möchte
aber auf aaron hunt diskussionen und von
monika
[Musik]
durch mir geschrieben dass
gäste simonetta sommaruga dax ist
schnell sage was ist passiert
wir haben geredet
und der schwache start erstaunt sie kam
es so schnell ich dachte dass da
den preis um sie zu sehen würde höher
aber trotzdem beendest du den
hungerstreik jetzt nicht nur no go
das ist nur die ich dachte jetzt zwingt
sie die kampf an so dass wir am ende
hier seien einverstanden und sie macht
diese instruktionen für die
bundesversammlung also erwartet für die
zusage
von dieser präsentation über die
klimaanlage von simonetta sommaruga
waren die bundesversammlung
bundesversammlung und publikum das eine
ist ja sind ja die menschen die
vorbeikommen mit dir widersprechen viele
schöne sachen die du erleben darfst hier
also mir auch gesagt wie geht es dir
wenn du die kommentare ließ auch unter
der reportage viele sorgen du wärst
egoistisch sozial ein spinne es ist
unnötig
ja das ist ziemlich toll wie geht es wie
geht es dir dabei wieder das sei aber
die sache ist
generell macht es mir lachen und zu
sprechen weil ich manchmal dass die
sache nicht lese sind so dumm dann
kommen da durch die vorletzte wollte
mich weil ich bin auch vater und finde
sein verhalten sehr egoistisch ja er
sollte sich besser um seine kinder
kümmern arbeiten gehen und schauen dass
es ihnen gut geht meine frau meine frau
würde mich für so eine aktion sofort
findet vor die türe stehen
viele gehen ja auch die kinder und hat
eine frau
und meine tochter hat das gesagt zu so
eine gruppe der tram herzuhalten mir zu
helfen mein vater ist kein halten mein
vorteil ist nur mein vater und er
schützt mir und meinem bruder und meine
schwester und das was ich tue dies
stützte sie das sieht auch kommentare
reingekommen von wegen in afrika sterben
leute wegen hunger und du gehst jetzt
auch noch freiwilliger in den
hungerstreik dass das ein luxus problem
von unserem naja ist diese habe ich sehr
gern ein luxusproblem so die leute die
können solche sachen schreiben haben nie
hunger gesehen
wenn ich war ja ich habe eine schule in
madagaskar
gebaut für kinder so sie wären eine
bessere zukunft haben ihre zukunft ist
heute und heute sie sterben von huggel
es ist kein luxus das ist ein luxus des
kämpfen ohne risiko an das was ich
schweizer tun ich habe meinem und
demonstrationen die mahd dann gehe ich
nach hause und ich kann fernsehen
schauen
das ist luxus audianer 87 schreibt die
politiker interessieren sich doch eh
nicht wenn jemand im hungerstreik
sie sind interessiert sind fragt mich
jetzt und für nicht
in bar zu sprechen was ist interessant
wir frauen haben mehr mut als männer in
die parlaments und
um mit mir zu sprechen was ist so toll
es gab aber nicht nur negative
kommentare
zb
sponsor hat geschrieben junge junge die
kommentare hier er wird hier als
egoisten bezeichnet opfert sich aber für
seine familie und uns selbstloser kann
man nicht handeln mich würde
interessieren was der mann für einen
hintergrund hat wie ist das zu
entscheidungen kommen das ganze jetzt
durchzuführen du hast mir im ersten
gespräch aus zu mir erzählt du warst
vorher nie
aktivist zum ersten tag hungerstreik
warst du du warst nie demonstrieren
gegangen im zivilen ungehorsam
das kann ich mal ein teil nichts absolut
nichts ich hatte die meine normale
normales leben es war arbeit der
mit den kindern spielen mit dem
kochen was passiert die nächsten tage du
wirst hier sein du wirst gespräch wir
haben angefangen mit parlament ehren zu
sprechen so sie würden
frau sommaruga helfen um die richtige
entscheidung zu nehmen
so sah er sich fühle sich nicht allein
und so weiter so das ist jetzt nicht nur
von dir sondern bekommt auch innerhalb
von der politik jetzt ich hoffe so ich
weiß noch nicht da war ich hoffe
hungerstreik ist ein geduld übung am
ende
jetzt gehts weiter mit dem nächsten
interview führte
danke danke danke
ich habe mein der courage im westen lebt
ja so knapp stück kommentar an guillermo
zum hungerstreik sind auch kommentar zu
der reportage oder zum persönlichen ich
möchte die u23 klasse pilot switzerland
schrieb zum beispiel an alle diejenigen
die meinen sie leisten einen riesen
beitrag zum klimaschutz weil sie nicht
fliegen die fliegerei macht zwei bis
drei prozent des gesamten ausstoßes aus
überlegt euch mal wie groß jetzt euer
beitrag zum umweltschutz wirklich ist
ich habe das buch zu dem thema klasse
und hanna mal nach gelockert wie viel
das ich und ich bin tatsächlich auf 40
prozent wird davos macht am globalen
ausstoß von co2 also für alle emissionen
wo man hand in der schweiz sind
allerdings 21 prozent wo airlines
mobilität falls das sind aber ein auto
das ist schifffahrt aber die schweiz
flüge mir durchschnittlich extrem viel
pro kopf und komisch dass auch in
relativ kurzen seil vom vortag druck und
ich kann das von mir leute im umkreis wo
jetzt für wolfgang zum beispiel auf
mexiko und party machen und zu einem
langstreckenflug buchten und ich denke
da muss das wirklich sie klimakrise nun
wolfgang und deine lüth wo geht s
produkt nur fair trade fair produziert
keine emissionen über die hersteller
kämpfen und ich denke die stunde nervig
mehr geburt mensch und so und ich sehe
das nicht nur bei mir sondern ich sehe
das aber die kommentarspalte von der
reportage möchte das wegschieben vor
sich und ein videokommentar innerhofer
der marlies marian und war es gab
eigentlich genau wie deine kumpels ziel
der klimawandel zum stillstand bringen
co2 grenzwerte war verstand man unter
klimakrise ein videokommentar wo ähnlich
ist ihnen von josef kann man wirklich
von einer globalen erderwärmung sprechen
obwohl es in der schweiz im vergleich
zum vorjahr durchschnittlich 1,5 grad
kälter war als im vorjahr ich muss ganz
kurz auf den brief klimakrise egal man
redet ja von klimawandel
es ist aber so dass viel bequemer waren
sie hat schon immer stattgefunden als
letzte tour sieger hat immer ein
klimawandel jetzt ist aber nur so dass
der klimawandel es so sprach wurden die
letzten jahrzehnte mann hans übrigens
auch letzte mal gesehen dass man von der
klimakrise red wir sind aktuell bei der
erderwärmung vor 1,2 grad dass ich aus
dem bericht von der pc sie gott das
hervor und bei jedem zettel grad
verändert sich biologie von planet es
verändert sich biotop und somit auch
prozess wo sich aufwand für andere zum
beispiel außen recht vom abc hervor dass
takkt ist also eine nordpol dass der
tipping point erreicht ist also dass der
clip punkt erreicht ihr könnt auch diese
nette die wird aus der vor schmerzen
experte hat berechnet dass bereits im
jahr 2004 auch das erste mal im sommer
wird ohne meeres easy und das hat extrem
folge auch für uns menschen
klima aktivismus wenigsten porter
schauen werde zeige ich euch ein teil
der favorit sagt ich möchte etwas mache
ich möchte darauf aufmerksam mache
jedoch weiterhin kommentiere sowohl bei
der reportage autorenkino ich würde mich
vorher und lese dir sehr gern und
verbesserte kanals abonnieren